it was a flight she begged her husband
not to pilot and it was the flight that
killed him
the wife of the captain of the Ukrainian
airliner that crashed in Iran is
consumed by grief
she's comforted by her father and
friends as they pay tribute to him and
the 10 other Ukrainian victims at Kiev
Airport it's from here that captain
volodymyr gap on encode took off and
never returned
katerina told me about their last
conversation did you feel nervous
because you knew the situation on the
ground and you knew your husband was
flying did you feel nervous on that
morning canoes no bhooloka kita pretty
austria bully Balam naga yeah priscilla
vanilla tea oppressively only needle at
north kisarazu cateura
no Ju [ __ ] on your shrooms coz are
using here to Nyctophobia
yes das malaria does not really is a
planner on a young Lee true hero
Priscilla starts the ball of flames
marks the final moments of Ukraine
International Airlines flight 752 it
came down hours after Iran blasted
missiles at us targets across the border
in Iraq Iranian air defenses would
doubtless have been on alert at that
time for the u.s. firing back
these black box flight recorders will
hold crucial data about what happened
American officials believe an Iranian
anti-aircraft missile shot the plane out
of the sky most likely by accident
Tehran insists this is wrong
claiming a technical failure on board
most Western governments disagree we do
believe that it's likely that that plane
was shut down by an Iranian missile we
are we're gonna let the investigation
play out before we make a final
determination it's important that we get
to the bottom of it I've been on the
phone I was on the phone with President
Solinsky just before I came here I was
on the phone with my Canadian
counterpart they were working to get
their resources on the ground to conduct
that thorough investigation we'll learn
more about what happened to that
aircraft in Ukraine the main spy agency
says a missile or terrorism is to blame
but ministers are
keeping an open mind which way are you
leaning a missile or a tragic accident
on the plane we're analyzing the pieces
of the body of the plane we're analyzing
the bodies of four people perished in a
crash
they're in hospitals right now we're
analyzing the chemical residues only on
the body of the plane we will come to
our conclusion we don't want to come to
them right now but this American
commercial pilot on a trip to Kiev has
little doubt absolutely I believe the
airplane was shot down by a
surface-to-air missile without a doubt
oh and why do you think that well just
do the nature of the the crash the
aircraft was just coming out of the
airport on departure I believe it had
only climbed to about 8,000 feet and
witnesses said they saw the airplane
engulfed in flames and on fire and a key
component to my my feeling is that the
pilots never made it an emergency Mayday
call answers to what caused the crash
won't blunt the grief of the families of
these victims but the truth will help
them understand and seek justice from
whoever was to blame
Deborah Haines Sky News Kiev